- once the pot I know Dyson Hofer agrees
with those who say the makan and not the
Cayenne is Porsches best SUV others say
it's just a Porsche made out eq5 but
there's no doubt the makan GTS is
special he says you could hear it a part
of the GTS identity is the individual
look and that's what sets this makan
apart from its siblings Porsches GTS
design has already tried and tested and
involves lots of black the sport design
package is standard but unique to this
variant are the matte black elements the
side blades the tinted tail lights and
black badging GTS stands for Gran
Turismo sport and like most things
portion that has its origins in racing
this Mekons GTS is the tenth member of
Porsches GTS family position between the
makaan s and the Macan turbo it might
well be seen as the Stuttgart based car
makers attempt to push the crossover
between sports car and SUV to its limits
the 3 litre 265 kilowatt
gasoline-powered engine paroles the GTS
from 0 to 100 km/h in just 5.2 seconds
our test version lists for just under 94
thousand euros in Germany nearly twenty
thousand more than the base model
yeah possum on vine hold points out that
the Mekons sells better than the Boxster
Cayman and 911 put together it may not
be as sporty as the turbocharged version
but it cost less and sounds just as good
inside the logos make sure everyone
knows this is a GTS the interior is also
unique to the model both driver and
passenger are cradled in newly developed
sports seats with Alcantara centers and
the GTS logo emblazoned on the headrests
[Music]
along with the powertrain the Porsche
engineers have reworked the suspension
for the Mekons GTS setting it 15
millimeters lower than the makaan s and
giving it a sporty ER feel contributing
to the enhanced driving dynamics is the
porsche traction management or PT m4
all-wheel drive it distributes the
thrust between the permanent rear-wheel
drive and the front axle the
electronically controlled dual clutch
allows the optimum distribution of power
and forward Drive in every situation
[Music]
at Clinton - fine hold the Porsche Macan
GTS sounds like a genuine eight cylinder
but picks up like a sports car
the 265 kilowatts of power make it's two
tons feel more like one coming home from
the office he says you almost want to
take the dirt road detour una house
ganimard and avec you buddy laughs mm